on parle de calage en tout cas
martiniquais n'ont pas pas de kalach en
tant que co artistes dont un seul comme
on dit de la martinique et quand il se
passe quelque chose comme ça on le dit
minimes d'une manière extraordinaire et
ça me choque en tant que maman et en
tant que maman c'est mon rôle à ce
moment là bien que je connaisse ma place
par rapport à l'artiste par rapport à sa
manager par rapport à haut niveau et de
travail des équipes qu'ils ont c'est mon
amant de maman de deux que vous me
donner l'opportunité de parler de
l'histoire c'est un artiste il est très
haut
il est pour moi de vous êtes déjà aux
états unis parce qu'effectivement il n'a
pas le look français il a plutôt un look
jean rihanna ou ici aurait choqué les
choque pas aux états unis il peut-être
qui choque en france parce qu'il est
tellement poids américain mais c'est mon
rôle en tant que maman de dire écoutez
c'est bon je sais où est ma place de
maman et je sais à quel moment je dois
parler aussi
oui j'attends des informations et je
suis sereine pourquoi parce que s'ils
s'y cache
kevin a fauté il devra assumer parce que
moi je lui a appris à faire son lit et à
se coucher dedans et je vais dire aussi
une chose que toute chose concourt au
bien de ceux qui aiment dieu et qui a
lâché un homme qui aime dieu n en parle
tout le temps de calage devra non
seulement assumer ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'il a fait une connerie et en plus
mûri en effet qu'il a fait mais ça et là
je vous assure que j'ai bien dormi en ce
moment tout le monde mais fait
effectivement me dise antilles en
souffrance et cetera je comprends les
gens mais moi en tant que maman mon rôle
n'est pas de pleurer mon moins de 10 ont
ce qu'il faut dire au bon moment il doit
dire kevin si tu as fait une connerie
mon vieux tu verras si c'est la vie je
vais passer la pommade siggraph est une
bêtise qui devait pas faire